indoor malls in the valley plan to
reopen tomorrow after being shut down
for more than two months 8 news now
reporter Kristen Drummond visited
Boulevard mall to see how tenants are
preparing for shoppers a buzz of
excitement inside the boulevard Mall and
as you can see it's a little wild we're
all hands on deck come on down to the
boulevard more businesses prepared to
welcome shoppers back but a few get
ready for their grand opening
we've been waiting we were supposed to
open in April and now we finally get the
go-ahead to get this thing started
Renee Rubalcaba owns las vegas family
puppet theatre company if you're a fan
of say the Muppets we have muppet puppet
type play productions and we have puppet
making for all ages he plans to take
necessary precautions to keep people
safe and healthy that includes limiting
the amount of people in his store all of
our tenants will be at 50% capacity
guests can't expect a few changes when
walking in the mall signs that the
entrances will advise people to social
distance use a face covering sanitized
wash your hands as well as cover your
cough or sneeze we've got some markers
on the floor that indicate you know
where you should stand if you're
standing in line other adjustments
modifying ours taping off benches
resetting seating areas and security
encouraging people to wear masks and
they'll be roving the mall and making
sure that they assist people as needed
modifications for a new shopping
experience
Kristen Drummond 8 news now Galleria
Sunset Meadows and fashion show mall
also plan to open tomorrow didn't